y aquí tenemos la conformación eclipsada
del etano si alineamos los carbonos
podemos ver la proyección de newman para
la conformación eclipsada y tenemos
algunos hidrógenos verdes para que sea
más fácil visualizar la rotación del
enlace carbono carbon voy a rotar el
carbono frontal sin mover el carbono de
atrás ahora tenemos la conformación
alternada y si lo rotamos 60 grados nos
queda la conformación eclipsada si lo
rotamos de nuevo tenemos la conformación
alternada y si lo rotamos otros 60
grados nos queda la conformación
eclipsada si lo rotamos tenemos la
conformación alternada y si rotamos
regresamos a la conformación eclipsada
aquí tenemos una gráfica de las energías
potenciales de las conformaciones que
vimos en el vídeo empezamos con la
conformación eclipsada del etano que
tiene una cierta energía potencial y
conforme rotamos la molécula para llegar
a la conformación alternada podemos ver
que la energía potencial disminuye
entonces la conformación alternada tiene
una energía potencial menor a la de la
conformación eclipsada y cuando rotamos
nuevamente regresamos a una conformación
eclipsada observen que se necesita
energía para pasar de la conformación
alternada a la conformación eclipsada y
cuando pasamos de eclipsada a alternada
disminuye la energía si pasamos de la
alternada a ésta eclipsada aumenta la
energía pero cuando pasamos a esta
alternada disminuye
y cuando regresamos a la eclipsada la
energía aumenta nuevamente observen que
todas las conformaciones eclipsadas
tienen la misma energía potencial
podemos dibujar una línea y lo mismo
ocurre con las conformaciones alternadas
todas tienen la misma energía potencial
entonces las conformaciones alternadas
tienen menor energía que las
conformaciones eclipsadas y la
diferencia entre las dos es de 12 kilos
jules dormal lo escribiré
12 kilos jones por mol
cuando una conformación es más baja en
energía significa que es más estable
imaginemos que esta es una colina y
tenemos una roca justo aquí si la
comparamos con una roca que se encuentra
en la cima en física la energía
potencial en el piso es igual a cero
digamos que este es el nivel del piso
nuestra energía potencial
es igual a cero jules y para este valle
es igual a 10 tours
entonces necesitamos energía para
empujar la roca desde el valle hasta la
cima y podemos decir que la energía
potencial en este punto es de 22 jules
ahora esta posición final es menos
estable y es la energía potencial más
alta entonces una conformación a mayor
energía potencial es menos estable y a
menor energía potencial es más estable
la diferencia entre las conformaciones
se debe a la tensión torsional es decir
a la diferencia de energía que en este
caso es de 12 kilos urss por mol se le
llama tensión torsional y el origen de
esto tiene que ver con una de las
teorías del orbital molecular que habla
sobre la repulsión entre los pares de
electro
dice que la repulsión es mayor en la
conformación eclipsada observen que este
enlace está muy cerca de este y ocurre
lo mismo por aquí y también aquí
entonces estos enlaces están muy cerca
en la conformación eclipsada mientras
que en la conformación alternada podemos
ver que están más alejados por eso la
repulsión de electrones es mayor en la
conformación eclipsada hay mayor energía
mientras que en la conformación
alternada la molécula es más estable la
energía total es de 12 kilos por mol y
tenemos tres pares de hidrógenos
eclipsados aquí tenemos un par 2 y 3
entonces podemos decir que por cada par
de hidrógenos en la conformación
eclipsada la energía es de 4 kilos jules
por mol cuatro kilos urss por mol para
este par de hidrógenos 4 kilos por mol
para este par y 4 kilos por mol para
este que nos da en total 12 ya vimos que
la conformación alternada del etano es
más estable que la conformación
eclipsada y para pasar de la
conformación alternada a la eclipsada
necesitamos energía a temperatura
ambiente existe la energía suficiente
para que la conformación pueda cambiar y
cuando se alcanza el equilibrio
obtenemos un 99% de moléculas en la
conformación alternada y sólo el 1% en
la conformación eclipsaba
la conformación alternada es más estable
que la eclipsado